قليل تبعنا كلمه لرئيس الوزراء الياباني
وهو يعلن التعديلات على الاستراتيجيه
الدفاعيه اليابانيه والتي اقرت همم الاولى
من نوعها منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه ينضم
الينا من طوكيو مراسلنا فادي سلامه اذا
فادي يعني كلمه لافته واستراتيجيه جديده
همم تسلط الضوء على اعتبار الصين همم يركز
عليها وتثير القلق بالنسبه لليابان حدثنا
في هذه الكلمه
نعم بالاضافه بالطبع الى ذكر الصين على
انها تحديد الاستراتيجيه الاول في ماده
الولايات المتحده اليوم هذا الاقرار
للوثائق الثلاثه التي تحدد استراتيجيه
الدفاع اليابانيه هذا الاقرار يعتبر اكبر
تغيير في سياسه اليمن الدفاعيه من دونها
نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه القانون
اليابانيه يمنع القوات اليابانيه من
المشاركه فيها اعمال قتاليه خارجه حدود
البلاد ولكن في عام 2016 كان هناك التفاف
على هذا على هذه الفقره من الدستور قده
رئيس الوزراء الراحل
قوات اليابانيه حق الدفاع الجماعيه
لمساعده قوات حليفه بطبعه القوات
الامريكيه الان هذا التعديل الجديد على
استراتيجيه الدفاع اليابانيه يمنح القوات
اليابانيه حق همم هجوم مباشر على دوله
اخرى وهذا كان امرا لا يمكن تصديقه طبعا
خلال السنوات
طبقه ورغم ذلك همم هذا الحق الذي تمتلكه
الان القوات اليابانيه يتم السيطره عليه
من خلال سلسله من الاجراءات ومن شروط
المحدده مثلا يجب ان لا تشم هذه القوات اي
ضربات ضد ارض اخرى او دوله معديه الا اذا
كان هناك تهديد حتمي للاراضي والارواح
اليابانيين ايضا يجب ان يكون هناك ايضا
همم ان يكون الرد بالحد الادنى وان لا
تكون هناك وسيله اخرى لتجنب مثل تلك
الهجمات بالاضافه الى هذا الحق بشني ضربات
همم اليابان بها هجمات مضاده او ضربات
مضاده ايوه طبعا التسميه التي كانت ذكرت
سابقا وهي ضربات السباقيه واثاره الكثير
من الحساسيه داخل الشارع الياباني لانها
بالفعل كانت تغيرا همم 180 درجه عامه كانت
عليه الحكومه السابقه
تعديل في الاستراتيجيه الدفاعيه هل له
تاثير على السياسه الخارجيه والدبلوماسيه
لليابان باقتضاب لو سمحت
بالطبع همم بعض الكتاب هنا الكتاب
الصحفيين ذكروا بان هذا يوقظ المارد
الياباني اليابان تتراس الان مجموعه بدا
من الشهر القادم ستطرئس مجموعه السبع ايضا
ستخذ مقعد في مجلس الامن الدولي وهناك
رغبه بوضع اليابان من جديد على المنصه
الدوليه ولذلك قد نسمع اسم اليابان وتركيا
كثيرا خلال الاشهر القادمه خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالصين وكوريا الشماليه